[Música]
gostaria de iniciar aqui com esse evento
que aconteceu há 25 anos
essa é a minha formatura de segundo
jardim onde estudava numa pequena escola
pra funcionários da aeronáutica
essa é foi um evento simples mas muito
marcante na minha vida porque eu não vou
saber como explicar para vocês mas
aprendi a ler e escrever sozinho minha
mãe meu pai ficou muito assustado
abismado com a situação os professores
também e acabem se tornando o orador
além daquela pequena formatura é mas
mais importante do que o fenômeno nem se
foi a quantidade de rótulos que eu
acabei recebendo naquele momento
falaram que era um gênio que é um
superdotado e mais um monte de outras
bobagens e eu passei a fazer exatamente
aquilo que as pessoas esperavam de mim
passei a estudar muito tirar boas notas
e entrar numa boa faculdade na promessa
de um futuro próspero e assim eu fiz
quando fui pro meu
antes de entrar no ensino médio também
um problema aqui no agora
antes de entrar no ensino não tá pensa
antes de entrar no ensino médio fiz
prova para o colégio militar de brasília
é uma prova difícil onde eu consegui um
bom resultado foi o sétimo lugar geral
primeiro lugar em matemática
depois entrei para a faculdade de
engenharia mecatrônica o curso que na
época tinha terceira maior nota de corte
perdendo apenas para direito e medicina
e como a gente costuma brincar na
engenharia é um curso difícil entrar mas
muito mais difícil ainda de sair e com
18 anos eu passei no meu primeiro
concurso público fui trabalhar na
aeronáutica como se viu apenas a poucos
quilômetros daquela pequena escola onde
eu fui orador na minha no segundo jardim
bom e recebi assim alguns títulos e
rótulos como eu falei pra vocês mas
talvez nenhum foi tão clínico e
izzo como o que minha irmã dizendo em
diversos momentos em que a gente cresça
junto que ela falava em vários momentos
assim uma não consigo entender com uma
pessoa tão inteligente consegue ser tão
burra e por que ela devia isso porque em
diversas situações e lá me pedir pra
trocar uma lâmpada pagar uma conta no
banco ou colocar a máquina de lavar para
funcionar eu travava e dá um jeito de
falhar e e e isso acabou sendo mais
significativo para mim quando eu fui
trabalhar pela primeira vez na área de
engenharia trabalhando como trainee numa
no entorno de 18 anos de brasília é e lá
e me deparei com diversos funcionários
muitos deles têm menor foi aberto
trabalhando na área de mecânica e
elétrica e o que é interessante ele é
que mesmo sem uma formação acadêmica e
resolviam quase todos os problemas do
chão de fábrica e eu com um diploma
embaixo do braço universidade federal
sabendo resolveu integrar as duplas
integrais triplas transformado de
laplace eu não conseguia resolver
diversas daquelas situações
bom eu trabalho há cinco anos com
educação e eu percebi que esse problema
não é apenas meu não é apenas no brasil
mas é inclusive em grandes potências
educacionais como cingapura cingapura
vem liderando os grandes rankings da
educação no pisa essa grande avaliação
internacional é mais o que foi se
percebendo em cingapura que esses alunos
que são muito bons em resolver provas
quando chegava no mercado de trabalho
eles faziam muito bem atividades que
estão relacionadas à sua área de
formação atividades muito bem
delimitadas
mas quando era pra fazer coisas
diferentes quando eles precisavam
improvisar tomar riscos inovar
aí eles trabalhavam fazendo com que o
ministério da educação de cingapura
passa a se preocupar com essa situação e
incentivar atividades criativas ali bom
é nesse processo a gente percebe uma
grande epidemia na educação um mundial
isso porque a gente está passando por
situações altamente corrupto
mas como diz o universidade oxford cerca
de 2 bilhões dos empregos vão deixar de
investir até 2030
isso acontece porque vivemos essa
revolução tecnológica na área da
robótica inteligência artificial
biotecnologia nanotecnologia e bom
surgindo iniciativas como narrative
science uma startup com a inteligência
artificial que transforma dados em
narrativas considerado pelo fórum
econômico mundial
uma das como das 61 tecnologias mais
promissoras de 2018 e o que é mais
interessante é que a nativ time chegou a
escrever artigos para a forbes
você não conseguia diferenciar se aquilo
foi feito por um ser humano ou por uma
máquina ou seja jornalistas fiquem
ligados vocês podem ser substituídos por
uma inteligência artificial ea gente não
precise muito longe tem uma startup
brasiliense chamada legal leve que
consegue fazer hoje cerca de 90% das
suas petições em massa utilizando a
inteligência artificial vindo aí como
uma possibilidade de abertura no gargalo
florence com mais de 100 milhões de
ações judiciais
e quando a gente vê essas situações a
gente imagina o que vai ser o nosso
futuro e esse futuro que nem eu e nem
ninguém aqui é capaz de prever
bom antes de falar do nosso futuro é
importante a gente analisar o nosso
presente
hoje nós temos a taxa mais alta da
geração nem-nem 23 jovens buscando dos
jovens brasileiros não trabalham e nem
estudam e por outro lado nós temos
alguns jovens que já conseguem ganhar
até milhões sem nenhuma formação
acadêmica trabalhando com o tráfico
patrocinado em redes sociais flop chip e
várias outras formas que a gente nem
imaginaria a festa de 15 anos
então quando a gente pára pra pensar no
nosso processo de educação informação
tem habilidade que estão sendo
totalmente deixados de lado como a
criatividade a criatividade ela não é
importante apenas para a expressão
artística impressão pessoal para a
publicidade
a criatividade ela também é uma
excelente ferramenta para forro
resolução de problemas mas problemas não
previsíveis de problemas que
que são diferenciados porque os
previsíveis a inteligência artificial e
robótica já vem resolvendo muito bem
além disso a criatividade vem com uma
excelente ferramenta para a gente finge
inventar perante a essas mudanças
imprevisíveis
criatividade não é luxo criatividade é a
necessidade ea gente percebe que isso
não está no pilar das grandes
instituições de educação no brasil e no
mundo se a gente pára para pensar numa
instituição de educação de sucesso é
aquela que mais aprova vestibulares
principalmente federais com uma nota
alta do enem ea criatividade e deixada
como algo extra um estranho perceber
isso porque estamos há 13 anos dá até de
toque mais visto de todos os tempos de
torcedor que robson que dizia exatamente
como as escolas estão matando a
criatividade bom e estamos nessa
situação problema será que precisamos
então reinventar todo o sistema
educacional
a verdade é que já existe uma etapa da
educação que trabalha muito bem a
criatividade uma etapa que a gente não
respeita muito o jardim de infância para
e pensa numa sala de jardim-de-infância
de um lado a gente ver crianças
brincando com blocos de madeira tentando
construir o castelo mais alto possível
do outro tem crianças brincando com
tintas e ao misturar o amarelo com azul
ela descobre o verde e aí nesse processo
lúdico nesse processo divertido nesse
processo mão na massa processo prático
elas estão aprendendo sobre estruturas
sobre cores mais principalmente de como
funciona um processo criativo elas estão
passando por aquilo que a gente vai
chamar de espiral da aprendizagem
criativa
a primeira coisa que essa criança que
está criando o castelo com um bloco de
madeira é ela está imaginando o que ela
quer fazer é ela tá querendo saber o que
ela vai criar até ao castelo tudo mais
ela vai criar de fato vai juntar os
blocos e vai criar em seguida ela vai
brincar vai criar uma história vai criar
uma torre mais alto muro em
enfim depois ela vai compartilhar vai
chamar os coleguinhas da professora e em
seguida ela vai refletir tudo que ela
fez mas é hábito os colegas deve ela
mesma já percebeu e aí ela vai imaginar
de novo e percebam que se imaginar não é
igual ao primeiro é completamente
diferente porque ela cresceu naquela
jornada tanto pelo feedback como da
própria vivência e esse processo muito
simplório que acontece com uma criança
no jardim de infância também é similar
ao que acontece por exemplo com o
desenvolvedor de aplicativos e também
está passando por uma espiral de
aprendizagem criativa ele também está
imaginando o aplicativo que ele quer
criar o ao problema que ele quer
resolver
ele cria de fato coloca o código e tudo
mais
ele brinca ele testa funções ele testa
procedimentos
ele compartilha no maps torna uma pré
histórico
ele reflete a partir do feedback dos
seus usuários e aí ele vai imaginar de
novo imaginar uma nova versão para o seu
aplicativo então esse processo é muito
simples acontece ao longo da nossa vida
inteira num processo criativo ea gente
fica pensando como trazer essa
experiência de um jardim de infância
para o resto da vida e graças a deus não
só eu estava me questionando isso mas um
grupo muito competente não é mais
chamado life long kindergarten jardim de
infância para a vida tudo e lá eles vêm
desenvolvendo tecnologias iniciativas
para que esse processo continue porque
na verdade não dá para um garoto de 17
anos fica brincando de massinha de
modelar e ficar brincando de quarentinha
e criaram diversas iniciativas como leve
mais torne uma parceria com a lego onde
eles conseguem criar robôs é controlar
motores e sensores participar de
campeonatos e projetos que já são
conhecidos do brasil conhecido no brasil
e no mundo inteiro ou iniciativas como
scratch uma linguagem de programação em
blocos onde as crianças conseguem criar
jogos animações e o que mais tiver na
mente delas são iniciativas incríveis e
poderia estar várias outras por aqui mas
quando a gente vê algo tão longe vindo
de boston
a gente imagina como trazer isso pra
realidade brasil
não é que a realidade onde os
professores estão sendo valorizados onde
a gente não tem infraestrutura como
trazer o emancipar o brasil e como a
gente pensa em relação a isso nada
melhor do que se espelhar em dois
exemplos como o da professora débora
garófalo
uma professora de são paulo de uma
escola pública em uma região de alta
vulnerabilidade trabalhando na região de
favelas e que com sua formação em letras
e pedagogia aceitou o desafio de
trabalhar com informática educativa com
aqueles alunos e não tendo muito recurso
ela se apoiou em outro problema o
problema do lixo
ela pegou no lixo é feito um processo de
coleta seletiva com seus alunos na
região pra tanto dá um descarte correto
como também proveitar e materiais para
trabalhar com robótica educacional e os
resultados foram incríveis
ela teve cerca de de uma queda de 93 por
cento da taxa de evasão escolar 93 por
cento de queda na taxa de trabalho
infantil
o ideb que essa grande avaliação das
escolas públicas subiu de 4,2 para 5,2 e
ela coletou junto com seus mil alunos
uma tonelada de lixo naquela região
a professora débora faz um trabalho
incrível e ela teve a onde ser
contemplada com uma das 10 melhores
professoras do mundo em 2019 segundo o
globo to live considerado o nobel da
educação
então a gente ver histórias como essa a
gente se inspira e o que seria
interessante é o brasil para o nosso
crescimento seria como criar um exército
de bela garrafa dezenas centenas
milhares de professores como essa para
transformar a realidade dos nossos
alunos e esta tem sido a proposta do
curso online eu criei arduino do bloco o
código o arduino é uma ferramenta que
permite você criar protótipos robótica
de cerca de dez vezes mais baratas que
os 15 rebotes educacional e b ea gente
vem capacitando professores de todas as
regiões do país trabalham em áreas
totalmente distintas desde história
sofia artes geografia matemática física
trabalhando na robótica não o simples só
pela robótica em si mas em um processo
de aprendizagem criativa e tivemos a
honra de contemplar diversos trabalhos
como o professor jesus do interior do
paraná que criou um protótipo de mexer
automatizada que consegue abrir sozinho
com uma tampa de papelão ou então
trabalhos como o da professora ruben
rodrigues de santos que criou um homem
de lata mec pode interagir com as
pessoas quando tiver que então tudo é
repetir a favor inclusive então muito
interessante trabalhos como esse e mais
importante do que esses professores já
estarem pão na mão na massa é como fazer
pra transformar a vida dos alunos e é o
que tem feito o professor leste bastos
de uma região rural aqui de goiânia que
vem trabalhando com seus alunos classe é
professor de língua portuguesa e n
italiano trabalho de robótica e
programação para trabalhar produção de
textos e criação de narrativas e isso é
um trabalho incrível que vem acontecendo
há menos de um ano e ainda assim ele já
consegue coletar dados incríveis como
aumento de 30% da nota dos alunos nessas
provas
quando a gente ea gente ver enfim várias
notícias da nossa mídia notícias ruins
notícias que nos colocam pra baixo e é
muito fácil a gente se desanimar nevo
tudo que está acontecendo e assim como o
professor miguel head and neck do grupo
do iphone de gatuno enfim eu também me
considero em pessimismo de curto prazo é
muito difícil a gente perceber é
soluções acontecendo agora parece que a
educação está totalmente voltada para um
estado que não vai dar muito certo que
não está preparando os alunos e que
é um caos né a verdadeira balbúrdia isso
é verdadeiro balde mas também deste lado
eu posso dizer que eu sou um otimista de
longo prazo a gente pode trazer uma
educação mais divertida mais prática
mais prazerosa para o aluno professor
mas acima de tudo mais significativa que
preparem eles para os desafios do século
21 e nesse ponto eu gosto de comparar
com uma situação da áfrica a áfrica ela
tem uma não tem infraestrutura de
telefonia fixa como a gente teve em
parte do brasil é nos estados unidos na
europa enfim e em 2000 existiam apenas
2% de telefonia móvel dos cidadãos com
telefonia móvel
mas esse número aumentou para 28 por
cento em 2009 chegando a 70 por cento em
2013 o que aconteceu na áfrica foi um
salto tecnológico ela não precisou
passar por todas as situações de
infraestrutura que a gente precisou
passar
ela simplesmente começou já a trabalhar
direto com a telefonia móvel e o que eu
venho propor aqui é um salto educacional
que o brasil faça um salto educacional e
aprendizagem criativa a gente não
precisa passar pelos mesmos processos
que as grande potências educacionais
passaram a gente já pode direto
trabalhar esses alunos nos desafios do
século 21
o curso é cada vez mais baixo e
engajamento é infinitamente maior
a gente pode nesse processo aumentar o
nosso índice do ideb aumentar as notas
nossas notas no enem e também melhorar
nossa posição no ranking do pisa
pode ser que isso aconteça pode ser que
não mas certamente teremos jovens
melhores preparados para os desafios do
século 21
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]